exactly one month
it's one month from today yes and
and that's when free agency begins and
teddy bridgewater is one of the
quarterbacks available in free agency he
was 5-0 as a starter for the saints last
year while drew brees was injured he
only has six starts though since 2015
because of the knee injury in august of
2016 that derailed his career
jeremy fowler of espn yesterday
suggested there will be a strong market
for teddy bridgewater with bridgewater
potentially making 30 million per year i
i did a double take i i
i coughed on uh what i was drinking even
though i wasn't even drinking anything
that's how stunned i was
30 million a year for teddy bridgewater
is so over the top beyond what he should
get especially in a year with this many
quarterbacks chris i was told last night
and see here's the thing even though did
i mention free agency begins a month
from today though it doesn't begin until
a month from today
it's already begun yeah because there's
so many quarterbacks so many agents
representing the quarterbacks and so
many teams have to figure out what
they're gonna do the communications have
already begun yes it's tampering nobody
cares they're all doing it so
i'm told that
somebody who wants to scare teams away
from teddy bridgewater so
teams will consider
their quarterback client is putting out
this bogus 30 million dollar number
because teams will see it and they'll
say screw that we're not paying
attention
right let's move on to the next guy yeah
it's amazing but this is just what we're
going to be dealing with over the next
month because free agency begins one
month from one month from today thank
you and we're saying that a lot because
our producer matt casey was just
absolutely just hell-bent on us saying
that so we're going to continue to say
it but it's so much better if you don't
say why we're doing it i want people to
think we're deranged all right well okay
fine they already know we're deranged i
mean come on we just need to let them in
on the rest of it okay
but it does seem like it is a smear
campaign i mean first off just at the
base level i mean right i mean you said
it who who the hell is going to pay him
30 million
i mean come on i mean that that's
ridiculous like so i love the guy yeah i
love him
right i mean we're debating whether to
pay tom brady 30 million we're not going
to throw 30 million at the teddy
bridgewater because of five starts over
the last three years now i think there's
going to be major action for teddy
bridgewater i do now is that action mike
here's to me is where is it get
interesting you know is it going to be
starter action is he going to like does
a team like the bangles or the chargers
say come in and be a starter the other
avenue i look at too that's going to be
interesting for teddy bridgewater is
like i think there's going to be teams
that are going to want them for the
similar way the saints wanted them like
if i'm the chicago bears i'm calling
teddy bridgewater if mitchell trubisky
has a slow start one and four one and
three teddy saved the day if i'm the
pittsburgh steelers i might think about
teddy bridgewater just to feel good so
our season doesn't fall down the toilet
if ben roethlisberger isn't ready to go
week one so it doesn't be punny action
but if i'm teddy bridgewater i want to
go to a place where i know i'm the
starter and that's where the contract
will tell us even though i don't think
he's gonna get 30 right right nick falls
got 22. i mean i think you need to be in
kind of that range to go into the season
as the unquestioned starter you don't
have to worry about being number two or
competing with someone else to be number
one either way he deserves a shot but he
ain't getting 30 million uh but we'll
see what happens when we're back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports